we have a story addressing the check
this out oh cool this is from nbc news
gender dysphoria is now covered by
disability law federal court rules
the ruling could become a powerful tool
to challenge legislation restricting
access to medical care and other
accommodations for trans people
advocates say
and this uh this pertains to the fourth
circuit court which is maryland north
carolina south carolina virginia and
west virginia but will inevitably be
cited in cases in other states
now
obviously this will go to the supreme
court it's going to be appealed the
story has to do with um
prison inmates uh i believe this was a
transgender here we go they say the
decision came in the case of a
transgender woman who sued the fairfax
county sheriff in virginia for housing
her in a jail with men the decision is
not limited to transgender people
challenging jail policies but also
applies broadly to all areas of society
covered by disability rights law
including employment government benefits
and services and public accommodations
the decision destigmatized a health
condition gender dysphoria and it says
that what congress did in 1990 wasn't
okay
now i can't see this standing
um because your mental state is not a
feat
is that it's not uh you used in terms of
your physical state
so if you
are um
if you are suffering depression they're
not gonna be like you you can't go to
this facility right
if you are having a mental
issue of some sort or i guess i look
with all due respect they're calling it
a disability it's project under
disability law
your mental state doesn't determine
whether or not you go to one facility or
another in many circumstances so this is
interesting i suppose you could argue if
someone's mental state was
lunacy psychosis you would go to a care
facility or a hospital instead of a
prison
many people don't they just go to prison
many people are clearly unwell
deranged depressed or insane and they
don't send them to hospitals
why would it be now that someone
with a a you know a mental issue
they could use that
to actually
affirm that mental issue and be
transferred to a separate facility you
see where i'm going with this like
i feel like if this did stand you would
have like jails that were strictly for
depressed people because your mental
state is not something that is a fixed
feature of your attribute like it
doesn't stay the same from day to day
and i wonder if they're trying to push
us toward the slippery slope of you know
your external genitalia is not
necessarily consistent with who you
really are inside so i feel like it's
just opening or setting a really bad
press and i do hope it's challenged i
hope it's knocked over all together well
like here's a question if i have um um
what is it called general body
dysmorphic disorder
will they
affirm that by amputating
amputating your body well so look for um
for people who are trans
gender affirming surgery as it's called
would be the reconstruction
uh removal of your reproductive organs
and then the the cosmetic alteration of
them
because you are depressed by it there's
a there's a a a
another um i think it's in the dsm-5 i
don't you call it disorder that is um
body dysmorphic disorder i think you
know you want to look that up because i
i i'm looking at the dsm-5 what aspect
of it body dysmorphic disorder can you
google that yeah i'll check it out uh i
think that's what it's called i could be
wrong that sounds right but there are
people who like my that is what it's
called yeah like my hand it's not my
hand i i'm like i need it removed
i mean a doctor is not going to cut your
hand off this is so interesting to me
because most people don't know this
about jk rowling but she under a
pseudonym wrote an entire she wrote like
a series about a veteran who had lost
you know the lower half of his leg in
the war and he came back to england and
he was dealing with murderous
psychopaths who wanted who had body
dysmorphic disorder and who wanted to
like amputate their hands and whatnot
and he was incensed by this obviously
because he had an involuntary amputation
he lost a leg in an ied explosion or
whatever so i i wonder if that's that's
that's a little bit off topic but i
wonder if that's contributed to their
view of her as a turf because she's been
like no if you want to amputate
something that's not necessarily just
something we should accept i i have no
issue with disability law covering this
i get it it makes sense the dsm-5 lists
it as a disorder whatever that's the
opinion of the medical experts and so if
someone is experiencing experiencing
this then
i don't know if that
does does disability law give you
guaranteed access to government funded
that's what i feel like this might be
aiming at is it's a funding mechanism
yeah
but but but think about any other uh
like i really i think dysmorphic body
dysmorphic disorder is the the best
analogy because we are not granting
those protections to these people
and if we're going to allow individuals
to undergo cosmetic surgery and the
removal of organs due to a disability
would that not apply to any other uh
disorder
it would and so i would i would say that
are the prisons not going to have to
amputate the arms of individuals who are
requested
yes are you are you saying that it's
because it will be doing harm
i mean it's it's a question of i would
say partially but it's a question of
does the state have to pay for it
right
sure i mean i think there's i think the
initial argument for me is is it is it
the right thing to do like is what
you're doing actually providing a
benefit
i i guess the the main issue is are
there any other circumstances where you
would be housed in a different facility
based on your mental state like if you
were supposed to go to a super max
prison
and uh
you said but i'm depressed by that i
want to go to a low security prison or a
prison camp would they go well we have
to depression is a disability
i'm pretty sure depression has a
disability
right i'm not sure i'll look that up i
don't know i'm looking at it now i want
to i want to say yes i want to see
depression consistent depressive
disorder depressive disorders
so what if you said um i get anxiety
attacks bereavement exclusion and
bereavement is excluded from the present
moment it's like i'm sad about what
happened to me kind of thing sure what
if you said super max facilities make me
depressed and give me anxiety attacks i
think that's a form of grief but i could
be wrong you could argue it's
bereavement well so like you're saying
this is a step on the road well how was
how was then putting a trans person in
their biologically biological sex prison
not grief right they're they're ruling
that if you're male but identify as
female you must be placed in the female
prison because of your mental state well
your creep would be over as soon as
you're let out because then you're no
longer in prison right you'd be grieving
because you're in prison
you're right so they can't lock you up
that's right wow actually i think no no
grief is not a disorder oh okay you're
allowed right right right but the point
is if
so so look what they're saying here is
that if you're biologically biologically
male identifies a woman and go to a male
prison that's a disability
discrimination that's what they're
saying that's what this article is
saying if i have persistent depressive
disorder caused by being in prison it's
causing me a disability that's an that's
a violation of my rights as a disabled
person right
i should be moved to a different
facility to be accommodated for this
it's really funny how prisoners uh well
we're talking about prisoners rights
you're here maybe you can tell me about
this a little bit you spent 70 uh you
have none you have none you have but
they want them but then i'm thinking
about like the horror of war and like
war prisoners and like
we're in such a luxurious time in
history that we're able to kind of
demand how we want to be treated in
prison
uh interesting yeah
it's funny right you can make all the
demands you want i mean they're they're
not gonna help you their job is not to
help you like i mean so i didn't really
have an opinion on prison ahead of time
you know but being there i definitely
have an opinion now my thought was
always you know well you did something
wrong so enjoy prison you know but i
don't think we should make it something
you enjoy though because the idea should
be you don't want to come back here so
making people comfortable and stuff i
mean it should be uncomfortable but the
psychological side of what they do to
you is
horrible i think it should be
rehabilitative rehabilitative is that
the word
rehabilitative the goal should be to
rehabilitate people
yeah it should so i read these stories
about they put people on an island and
scandinavian countries or whatever like
if you're a supermax they put you in an
island and it actually had the most
successful rate of reducing recidivism
and like reforming people
because you made them responsible for
their safety security and survival more
so than if they were in society
well look at australia i mean they're
doing great
i mean they were yeah very successful
penal colony
yeah and a continent yeah did you ever
get the vibe of isolation while you were
was it isolative because yeah so when
you come in if you're unvaccinated uh
they have to put you in uh either the
shoe which is a special housing unit and
i think at one point it was like 21 days
and then they dropped it down to five
days when i got there the issue is uh
the unit they put me in every time
someone new came in and reset the count
so when i first got there it was me and
some older guy and we you know we
chatted for a little bit but i mean i'm
just trying to keep to myself because
all i know of prison is shawshank
redemption and green mile so
um
you know we kept having more and more
guys come in so the unit got more and
more crowded we're sharing more little
less and less showers only half the
toilets work it gets uncomfortable uh we
ended up doing uh i think 17 days before
they actually put us in the other units
uh that was basically general housing
but i can't complain because
back when it used to be um two weeks it
was two weeks for 21 days uh they had
actually an entire unit and there i
think there's i think there's probably
about 100 beds in there bunk beds so
they can house about 200 people per
block
they got to i think it was 95 people at
one point and uh they had them housed in
there for over 80 days and you cannot
leave that unit like you are stuck there
they bring you sandwiches and you can't
leave what were most people in for um it
was kind of all over the place so in a
camp the only reason you can't be in a
camp is if you're a um
it can't be like a violent crime and you
can't be a chomo
so um what's that achomo is a child
molester okay you can't be that so um
which is a violent crime which which is
a violent crime yeah one completely
decree that and also it's it's also for
their safety so um most of the chomos
are put into uh low facilities i know
the one i was at i think the population
was something like 80 to 90 percent all
child molesters which is no it's
staggering but i mean they have their
own gang and stuff there you know like
you don't they
protect each other and
now for everybody else was like
financial crimes or what financial
crimes you know a lot a lot of people um
you know shady business dealings and
things like that a couple people i mean
i learned about uh ghost money and ghost
drugs so this is um
let's say you have a large company right
and everything i say came from came from
criminals so grain assault you know
everyone's innocent president um so
let's say you have a company and you
have someone that uh you know it's like
they do your business dealings you know
because you've grown so much you send
someone they have an illegal
conversation about possibly doing
something right or let's say um you're
having a conversation about about buying
drugs but there are no drugs you know
it's not actually happened yet if two
people come together and say
he had the intention of doing this
that's a charge really
that is a charge they call it um
oh conspiracy to commit either fraud or
conspiracy to do something wow so if two
two inmates you're saying two inmates
tell a guard that a third inmate is
doing so
this is in the free world it says this
is out of prison so the people that were
there right a lot of them are like a
conspiracy commitment fraud conspiracy
to to do you know regular fraud and
stuff i mean i was i wasn't there long
enough to get full details of everything
was a pretty short stint but
if two people say this guy had an
attention to to buy to buy drugs or have
a shady dealing and their ci's for the
federal government they can arrest you
on conspiracy yep so you'll get you
could be some dumb dude who's sitting
playing video games and drinking a beer
and then some guy goes hey man you know
we should do we should do this then or
otherwise right you want to do it and
then you could be oh yeah i guess i
don't know whatever i'm like boom gotcha
yep and then all of a sudden someone
comes back and you're doing you're like
what like what are you talking about i
was just watching friends reruns okay so
when someone asks you to commit a crime
you say no every time yeah but what if
you don't know
if you don't know it's illegal yeah take
a look at marijuana laws across the
country they they vary all over a lot of
people don't realize that like for
instance in west virginia it's illegal
in maryland it's legal what if someone
from you know lives in maryland where
it's legal and they're and they and a ci
is like hey you want to you know hang
out we're going to the range and then go
to the range so they drive to west
virginia and then they're leaving and so
they're like we're going to go chill my
buddy's house and they go to a chill's
house and then someone says hey you want
to bring some of this stuff over to us
that'd be really cool and they go oh
yeah sure i guess boom gotcha
talking about crossing state lines with
uh something illegal or whatever and you
feel like they don't you might not even
know where the state line is you said
it's called ghost ghost crime ghost
drugs so ghost drugs is a really
prominent one in there so if the drugs
were there or not you still commit to
the crime so they're gonna arrest you
with no drugs just the well they said
they were going to they showed up to
meets to go by it and the other one was
ghost what was the other one um it's a
conspiracy to commit fraud fraud and
again i'm not an attorney i'm not a
lawyer i've not studied law but these
are the stories you hear inside you know
when everyone in prison's innocent if
you ask them i didn't do it you know but
the stories you hear they're i mean
they're tragic you know and i mean like
what's an example uh well
it's hard you're not supposed to when
you get out you're not really supposed
to tell people stories it's that i mean
they make up a story that's that's
comparable but not related to any actual
person
i mean like give us a gist of like what
it would be like
um sorry i'm sorry what's your
questioning that's the thing
i don't want you to to spill the beans
on anyone's actual life story so could
you make up something that's akin so we
understand what it would be like
like um like what's an ex what's a
fictitious example of what a tragic
story would be in these circumstances so
like um
when i was in i'd say what broke me
everyone's got a cell phone where i'm at
there's a lot of contraband in there i
mean people were bringing them like wing
house wings at night they were doing
runs it was
absolutely cool like garbage
i don't know how that happened i didn't
see anything wings are awesome yeah i'm
actually blind on both eyes and can
barely hear yeah
yeah um but uh there was one guy um i
was staying behind uh reading the book
and i heard a guy uh singing happy
birthday to like his three-year-old on a
cell phone his crying kind of in between
and like that was
absolutely attracted to me and this
guy's in for for marijuana
you know what i mean i've wanted to put
webcams in these prisons for about 15
years like just even if it writes people
if the guards are watching you have or
anyone have a conversation with their
family i mean at least they're having a
conversation that's why i see about
isolation earlier like psychological
isolation well i know the place i was at
used to be a women's camp and they
actually had the ability to facetime
their families like women have different
treatment than the men do in prisons
that sounds like a title nine violation
yeah well the only thing i hate about
the last story is that it came out you
know a couple months late because i
would have much rather preferred going
to women's prison
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there